so it's like Corelli deville - the are
and then Lenny like Lenny Kravitz and
you put them together and it makes you
Willa Lenny
Cruella Lenny sure is that the name of
your birth certificate
where are you from but where are your
parents from is that your real name
what does that mean my first name is
Willa Lenny you spoil that for me
kay is in kindergarten and you as an
umbrella w as in a whale it's easier if
I sing it to people okay cool it Lenny
[Music]
I'm calling to put in the reservation
for two for Friday night the name for
the reservation you can just put it
under the letter K that's a hard name to
pronounce Wow your name is Sol you need
that must have been a hard name as a kid
do you have a nickname thank you for
meeting with me this is really great of
course yeah and so it was cool alone eh
no extra accent just cool illa lemming
oh I got it I got it with a little money
[Music]
it's actually super easy it's just Cola
Lenny that's a mouthful I'll never be
able to say that my weekend was filled
with Tchaikovsky a little Schwarzenegger
and Game of Thrones marathon cuz I love
those Targaryen you don't look like I
thought you would
whoa didn't think he'd be a woman I
didn't think you'd be American you're
new right I'm Ryan
oh hi Ryan I'm room Amir no I'm ro army
um ro Omar yeah sure happy birthday oh
my
[Music]
are you Chloe yeah what's your name a
little mu oh cool what's your name
little any kind of hard to say it's cool
eleni eleni
[Music]